[Música]
bueno yo vengo hablando de de
información
y porque la información porque yo
considero que la información que el ser
humano ha generado a través de su
existencia en nuestro recurso más
preciado ahora no en el dinero
no son los carros no son penadas es la
información y por qué porque nos ha
tomado tanto tiempo llegar a donde
nosotros estamos ahora
que tendríamos que volver a pasar todo
ese tiempo para volver a generar y
piensen imagínense qué
ustedes viajen a la prehistoria diez mil
años atrás qué pasaría si ustedes no
llevan nada de información no han
aprendido
pudiéramos dejar de ese cavernícola que
pudiera eso pudiera dejarlo
pero si nosotros nos lleváramos los
libros que también las universidades
si nos lleváramos la matemática la
física y la química lo mejor nosotros
podemos llegar hasta donde estamos ahora
pero marc un hombre yo tengo la
confianza de que una sola persona que
viaje con esa información puede llevar a
la humanidad a cómo está ahora
bueno no no a la población que está
ahora porque sería ridículo no podemos
reproducir tan rápido pero si alá a los
niveles tecnológico que tenemos ahora
pero
yo veo un problema en el que nosotros no
somos muy eficientes guardando
información
nosotros destruimos nuestra información
muy a menudo la guerra en el pasado han
quemado muchísimos libros y han quemado
bibliotecas completas como en el caso de
la biblioteca de alejandría
nosotros no tenemos forma de saber que
se perdió en la biblioteca de alejandría
porque se quemó algunos libros tenían
copias por otra biblioteca del mundo a
lo mejor también daban ahí se quemaron
pero permanecieron en otros sitios pero
muchas cosas se perdieron que a lo mejor
eran importantes
pero se perdieron para siempre esa
información no puede ser restaurada no
podemos unir las partículas de humo de
nuevo y hacer el libro con las letras
y yo les pregunto ustedes de qué pasaría
con la información de nosotros en la
actualidad
esta información está a salvo
si la sociedad colapsa todos esos discos
duros sobrevivir
pero los libros son un poquito más
eficiente aunque los libros se pudren a
lo mejor la pintura en las cuevas es una
forma más eficiente de guardar
información
pero yo no voy a decir cuál es la forma
más eficiente de guardar información que
ha conocido el ser humano la forma más
eficiente de conservar nuestra
información es el adn y por qué porque
la naturaleza estado haciendo eso
durante millones de años y ha
permanecido ahí la ha mantenido más
tiempo bueno nosotros somos parte de la
naturaleza que conserva esa información
desde el inicio de la vida
no solamente qué
ha logrado mantener por mucho tiempo de
que es eficiente
toda la información que hemos generado
que no toma
muchísimo libro y disco duro si
pudiésemos almacenar toda la información
de la humanidad en la forma del adn de
la molécula del código genético pudiera
estar en su habitación ahora mismo
todo
todo lo que nosotros hemos hecho
escuchar y estoy pudiera estar en su
habitación ahora mismo y en de todo el
mundo y todo lo que se ha borrado si
estuviera en la forma de la derecha
y de hecho ya recientemente hemos podido
traducir libros
el resto difícil a un código bien
en la computadora utilizan código
binario el adn de 4 y cuaternario
y bueno exactamente pudiera estar
guardado en su habitación
pero lo que yo no vengo a decir no es
eso yo soy la información de nosotros
los ser humano y lo más importante que
tenemos ahora pero
la información que está guardada dentro
de la célula de todos los seres vivos de
todos los organismos de la biosfera
es más voluminosa que toda la
información que ha generado el ser
humano y si quisiéramos almacenar la
información del código genético de todas
las especies descubiertas sin contar las
que no han sido descubiertas ocuparía
esa cifra que ha ocultado lo entiendan
sería lo equivalente a ese número
de la supercomputadora más grande que
tenemos hasta el día de hoy
no necesitamos esa cantidad de
supercomputadora para almacenar
información genética de cada una de las
especies y yo creo que ustedes saben que
eso es imposible para nosotros
pero está donde está es información es
información está guardada en todos los
montes del mundo
pero yo le voy a agregar un poco más a
eso no es solamente que hay mucha
información y que esa información es
importante una cosa que yo te diga que
hay más información en el adn que libros
correcto el correcto eso esto es un
argumento perfecto pero esa información
es más importante que newton que
pitágoras por qué
porque pues no tome pitágoras lograron
entender todo eso hace mucho pero
nosotros no entendemos esa información y
es útil esa información es útil y en qué
sentido puede ser esa información útil
bueno lo primero medicamento que
nosotros descubrimos fue a partir de
químicos que producían plantas y no
cualquier planta la aspirina es de un
solo tipo de planta que conseguimos el
salicilato de metilo para convertirle
una ciudad satelital y cilic lo
si no tuviera eso no pudiéramos
penicilina
él sufre por accidente un hombre estaba
cultivando bacterias y se le contaminó
con un nuevo usualmente una bota cuando
se te con también un cultivo de bacteria
con agua pero él no lo votó porque él
vio que alrededor de donde estaba el
hongo no habían bacterias a pesar de que
el hongo no estaba tocando y él dijo
como rayos las bacterias no pueden como
ellas miden 12 milímetros alrededor del
hongo y no crecen ahí y descubrió que el
hongo produce un antibiótico y ese fue
el primer antibiótico que salvó a la
humanidad
de cubierto por accidente en un hongo
que ni siquiera fue ido a buscar en los
lugares más remotos del amazonas' eso
apareció solo y contaminó su placa de
petri
es otro ejemplo un poquito más reciente
esa planta que le dicen todo el año se
llama bean cae originaria de madagascar
muy bonita y por eso se popularizó en
los jardines de casi todo el mundo aquí
yo creo que popular y que todos ustedes
la conoce y lo que nadie se imaginaba
era que esa planta produce un componente
químico que se llama vincristina que es
exclusivo para ella y qué
es el tratamiento más efectivo para la
leucemia en la actualidad
mi abuela murió de leucemia y esa era
una de sus plantas favoritas
de hecho en el cementerio ya tiene una
planta de ese mismo color y de esa misma
especie sembrada y ella no se imaginaba
qué
dentro de su plan tan favorita estaba el
tratamiento
tratamiento que se utiliza en la
actualidad en personas jóvenes tiene un
90 por ciento de efectividad
y nosotros estamos encontrando
tratamientos en lugares cercanos a
nosotros lugares familiares pero no
estamos encontrando ninguno de los
tratamientos en explorando las amazonas
porque
porque demasiado
ni siquiera podemos comenzar a descubrir
todo lo que hay alrededor de nosotros oa
lo mejor en la periferia
pero la cantidad de lo que falta era
algo que yo pienso nunca vamos a lograr
entender pero ahí está
la cura de todas las enfermedades por
está del lado de nosotros ahora mismo lo
que pasa es que no sabemos dónde buscar
ni para qué enfermedades en la parte
difícil entonces
es un importante pero es fascinante
también que la que toda esta molécula
penicilina aspirina
todos los componentes químicos están
compuestos de lewis carbono hidrógeno
oxígeno y tal vez un poco de nitrógeno
tener un poco de azufre y todo eso está
presente en el aire que nosotros
respiramos ahora
el aire que respiran tiene los átomos
para crear todas estas cosas que en
verdad son carísimas pero no tenemos la
tecnología para ponerlas en el orden
específico y crearlo componente que
nosotros deseamos producir
pero las plantas y los animales también
y esa información está guardada en el
adn en el adn tiene la información para
producir todo eso componente que
nosotros deseamos y que vale más que
logro
y eso yo solo puedo comprobar con una
pequeña historia en la insulina en una
proteína que nosotros necesitamos una
proteína necesaria para que el azúcar
entre a nuestras células y la insulina
es una proteína
una proteína y eso significa que una
molécula un poquito compleja nosotros no
somos efectivos sintetizando proteínas
la farmacéutica todavía detalles
haciendo moléculas sencilla nosotros no
sabemos cómo hacer proteínas pero esa es
la especialidad de la del inde el adn se
encarga de hacer político y eso son las
proteínas y nuestro adn tiene la
información para producir insulina la de
nosotros los animales
y para producir insulina una persona que
necesitaba insulina porque sufría de
diabetes nosotros necesitamos toneladas
de páncreas de cerdo para extraer un
potecito que a lo mejor le duraría par
de semanas y era extremadamente costoso
pero nosotros descubrimos que como está
escrito en su adn la información para
producir insulina que si nosotros
cogemos ese capítulo del libro y se lo
metemos en el libro de otra especie que
podamos reproducir con más facilidad
como una bacteria esa bacteria va a
producir insulina y de hecho esta es la
forma en la que se produce la insulina
en la actualidad no porque nosotros lo
sabemos artificialmente es porque
nosotros sabemos que el adn la sabe
hacer de una forma que nosotros no
entendemos pero si nosotros cogemos esa
de adn y lo ponemos en otro sitio va a
ser lo igual
y algo más sencillo
las fotos simples la fotosíntesis yo
creo que es un fenómeno que todo lo
conoce desde que estaba en primaria
pero en la actualidad no se comprende
verdaderamente cómo la planta puede
producir glucosa a través de la
fotosíntesis solamente con luz la
glucosa está hecha de carbono hidrógeno
y oxígeno y las plantas lo hacen con eso
mismo dióxido de carbono y agua y con la
luz producen glucosa una de las
sustancias más importante para la
humanidad de hambre es la gasolina de
todas las células incluyendo la de la
planta y la de todos los centros seres
vivos la planta la producen la almacenan
la utilizan a medida que la vayan
necesitando pero algunos animales la
roban y la utilizan para su propio
metabolismo
no tenemos idea la planta la gente las
reglas en gratis porque está en su adn y
nosotros no tenemos la información para
poderla hacer no la podemos hacer del
aire nosotros no podemos [ __ ] aire y
hacer azúcar
y eso está hecho de eso
entonces esos son los libros que nos
faltan por leer y nosotros no no no no
no lo tengo maltratado lee pero todavía
lo está manteniendo lo físico cuántico
dicen que un fenómeno cuántico
que está interviniendo en eso pero eso
todavía significa que no entendemos
y bueno
todo el mundo se quiere comer la planta
porque están produciendo eso es la
gasolina
incluso la gasolina está hecha porque
los dinosaurios organismo se comieron la
planta y la convirtieron en grasa y eso
se convirtió en petróleo al final todo
fue fotosíntesis
y eso ha provocado que muchos insectos
se la quieran comer y los insectos y las
plantas están librando una guerra tan
antigua como los posibles
venir
importantísima porque la planta todita
para no ser comidas tienen un
contraataque los insecto quieren comerme
yo desarrollo compuesto químico y la ven
y lina que le da el perfume a la
vainilla y a su vez kotscho el mentol
que le da el olor a la menta
la sola nina del tomate de un componente
tóxico de las obras la peperina la de la
ponencia la pimienta la capsaicina hace
que lo baje picking la nicotina del
tabaco que la adictiva y por eso la
gente se lo fuma cafeína que no te
pierdas todo eso no está hecho para
nosotros eso está hecho como insecticida
la planta deposita en ese tipo de
sustancia en sus hojas como insecticida
porque eso le cuesta energía
y ella producen todas un componente
químico diferente a la mayoría de las
plantas ni siquiera sabemos qué
componente químico produce le pusimos el
nombre de nicotina porque la planta la
conocimos primero que el componente o
sea por lo general llevan el nombre de
la planta cafeína se le puso cuando se
descubrió que la planta del café
producía un componente y
eso tiene una función y como toda la
planta producen componentes específicos
y los insectos se lo quieren comer el
contrataque de los insectos desarrollar
inmunidad pero no hubo ni moneda para
todo el tipo de componente porque eso
sería excesivamente costoso y real sino
que desarrollan una inmunidad a lo mejor
a una especie de planta y ahí viene la
especialización
y cada una de las especies de mariposas
por lo general se alimenta de unas dos
especies de plantas de cuello que
llamamos plantamos poder por eso las
plagas son específicas a la planta de
donde está
y esta mariposa de una mariposa especial
porque se llaman calixto y son endémicas
de las antillas mayores pero tenemos
varias de país y cada una es endémica de
su respectiva isla nosotros somos la
española la isla que tiene la mayor
diversidad de calixto en el mundo
y es inusual en términos de mariposa que
haya tanto endemismo
y es muy inusual que aunque todas son
endémicas de la española
hay diferentes especies endémicas de
diferentes sitios ni siquiera están en
la isla
se fijan de cerca porque son muy
parecidos
tenemos diferentes especies casi en
todos los sitios más de 20 y nosotros
sabemos que hemos corroborado que son
especies diferentes porque su adn es
bien diferente a pesar de que se vean
iguales y por qué a que sirves adn ese
adn no sirve para su aspecto físico
porque ella tienen tantas diferencias en
su adn
es adn contiene las instrucciones para
producir proteínas que a lo mejor son
las responsables de que ya puedan
tolerar ese componente químico que
produjo la planta con suave
estas son de diferentes lugares cada una
sabemos que se alimenta de una planta
hospedera diferente y ahí viene el
próximo término interdependencia eso es
algo que vemos en el ecosistema no todo
es al azar no todo como cualquier cosa
cada planta produce flores conforman
colores estructuras diferentes o no ven
al asad eso eso significa que un insecto
o un animal diferente la poliniza
nosotros pensamos que las abejas
polinizan todo y la verdad que la sabana
polinizan todo y es el mejor ejemplo es
una mata de chinola hay una flora de
chinola y esa vega se está bebiendo su
néctar pero la estructura donde está
depositado el pueblo no está rozando a
la abeja por que la abeja no tiene las
proporciones de su cuerpo de la forma
correcta y la flor de la chj no la está
diseñada para los abejorros acá primero
eso que le dan en la madera en sus
terrazas y que ustedes fumigan si usted
tiene abeja y no tiene abejorro
carpintero usted no tiene flor fruto del
chino la
por qué
la especie de planta tiene un método
diferente para su polinización
y por lo general utilizan especies
diferentes especies diferentes de
insectos especies diferentes de aves
como los colibríes
y algunas flores son polinizadas por un
murciélago usualmente hablen de noche
abren de noche las flores que son
polinizadas por murciélago y cuando son
polinizadas por el mismo animal usan
otro tipo de trata ya como esa dos
especies de flor depositando el polen en
diferentes partes de la frente del
animal para que no se mezclen polen con
el otro
y cuando no hacen eso florecen en
diferentes épocas del año es una
coincidencia por alguna razón las flores
florecen a diferentes épocas del año a
lo mejor tienen el mismo polinizador y
para evitar evitar este tipo de
consecuencia florecen en diferentes
épocas del año y eso se llama fenología
yo tuve el honor de participar en el
2012 en una predicción haití a conservar
los anfibios porque porque nosotros
entendemos que en este tipo de sistemas
interdependiente
las relaciones son muy complicadas son
difíciles entender no yo no creo que
nadie entienda un ecosistema a su
totalidad
y son irremplazables y ahí tiene uno de
los países que tiene
la mayor diversidad en el mundo
pero no solamente tiene la mayor
diversidad de anfibios del mundo tiene
el mayor porcentaje de especies
endémicas en el mundo
pero 98% de esas especies están en
peligro de extinción muchas en peligro
crítico
lo que lo hace el país con más especies
en peligro de extinción del mundo
solamente queda un 1% de cobertura
boscosa y la mayor parte de su población
que está más grande que nunca depende de
segundo por ciento para su subsistencia
y nosotros lo sabemos en esa expedición
tuvo como objetivo visitar en
helicóptero esos remotos lugares donde
no ha llegado la deforestación está
llegando y buscar esas especies para
salvar su material genético y el
helicóptero no dejaba y nosotros
recolectamos estos anfibios por lo
general en la noche
después que teníamos todo el material
genético preservado
eso fue llevado y preservado el
nitrógeno líquido
reservamos su adn porque sabemos que se
va a extinguir sabemos qué
ya sea en tono algo nuevo ya nosotros
perdimos mucha información que no vamos
a saber la perdimos la estamos perdiendo
mucha información y sabemos que se va a
perder mucho sabemos que nos vamos a
salvar línea menor farc
la mayor parte de esta información se va
a perder
y bueno
eso es una pena porque eso es una pena
yo puedo salvar el adn de todas las
especies del planeta yo puedo salvar el
adn de toda la especie del planeta y
meterlo a nitrógeno líquido toda la
especie de planta toda la especie de
animales toda la especie de hongo todas
las especies de bacterias guardar su adn
y hacer una biblioteca de nitrógeno
líquido porque su adn puede estar
guardado congelado
pero en eso suficiente
eso no es suficiente porque esto es un
sistema un sistema de elementos
interdependientes en donde las
interacciones entre los elementos pueden
ser más importantes que los elementos
mismos
entonces aunque nosotros tengamos todos
los elementos todas las especies han
sido descubiertos no de cubierta desde
el planeta y la congelé moho lamentamos
el zoológico y después restauraremos el
medio ambiente y la volvamos a poner eso
no va a funcionar porque es un sistema
nosotros no entendemos el sistema en
primer lugar
no sabemos cómo poner la pieza en orden
entonces no hay nada que salvar a lo
mejor si estamos salvando las especies
pero no estamos salvando la biblioteca
y ese es el mensaje luego que primario
son un recursos no renovables ese tipo
de ambiente con ese sistema de elementos
interdependientes algo que no podemos
restaurar si le pasamos un tractor y
volvemos a sembrar cualquier árbol no va
a ser lo mismo porque ahí no están esas
especies eso no es renovable en algún
lugar del país puede tener más bosque
que antes pero en ningún lado del mundo
están incrementando la cantidad de
bosque primario siempre está
disminuyendo porque es que no es
renovable entonces yo considero que lo
importante aquí es identificar cuáles
son los lugares que
contienen toda esta información cuáles
son nuestras bibliotecas más importante
en qué parte del mundo están no lo
sabemos tenemos que identificar dónde
están en la biblioteca es importante
dónde está guardada esta información
no en cualquier lado
muy pocos permanecen inalterados sin
formación no está en todos los sitios
por ninguno se ha visto es
y eso es lo que tenemos que priorizar
nosotros tenemos que priorizar nuestro
esfuerzo de conservación en identificar
los lugares donde están nuestra
biblioteca pero lamentablemente no lo
sabemos y nosotros las estamos quemando
seguimos disfrutando y lo peor de todo
es que estamos reforestando después como
que nada ha pasado
si quemamos nuestra biblioteca y
reportamos lo que estamos haciendo es
llenando una falsa biblioteca con libros
vacío fotocopia de su revista favorita
nada ahí no hay información a lo mejor
desde fuera se ve a medio bonito pero
ahí no hay nada quemaron
su recurso más importa
toda la información que puede o no
determinar la existencia de la humanidad
está siendo pisoteada y muchos ni
siquiera nos podemos dar cuenta porque
ni siquiera sabemos distinguir